perhaps what i find most admirable about
you is your strict
sense of ethnic and religious identity
as a jew um your jewish
your jewish background has clearly
played a significant role in
in influencing or shaping the political
social and cultural ideals and values
that you have
as well as your support for israel as a
nation state
so i'm wondering
then do you support the classical
definition of
of a nation as being demographically and
culturally homogeneous like that of
israel
similar to the definition that american
forefathers generally
upheld with exceptions of course
until the heart cellar immigration act
of 1965.
okay so uh one i want to correct a
mischaracterization you said that i take
a lot of pride in my ethnic and
religious identity i take no pride my
ethnic identity i take a lot of pride in
my religious identity
so there are a lot of people who have
been born jews who i just don't care
about
right like like noam chomsky was born
jewish he's a schmuck like i i don't i
don't care
at all bernie sanders born jewish
schmuck like i don't
so so the point that i'm making is that
religious identity is a different thing
because that's a set of ideas and values
religion is critical and the same way
the american declaration of independence
is critical
so when it comes to the definition of a
nation i would say that it is
very important that a nation have a
creed in common i'm not
particularly interested in having an
ethnicity in common when they say that
israel for example is ethnically
homogenous that's just not true israel
is filled with russian jews and
ethiopian jews and yemeni jews my wife
is a moroccan jew
so just because they all have a religion
in common doesn't make them ethnically
identical by any stretch of the
imagination
right again there's no it's pretty hard
to find somebody who's more ethical
ethnically non-identical than a russian
jew and an ethiopian jew
uh so the reason that i believe in
israel as a nation state
is because it's not for ethnic reasons
it's because of religious observance
reasons that israel is a place where the
religion of judaism can thrive and be
safe which i think is an important thing
i think the same thing is true in the
united states when it comes to the creed
of the united states i think america is
a credible country i think it's what has
made america great now that's not to say
that everybody who comes into the
country has an equal capacity to
assimilate to that creed
the assimilation capacity of people i
don't think has to do much with ethnic
identity i think it does have to do with
cultural identity i think there are
cultures that come into the country
people come from various cultures who
may not be as easily able to assimilate
because obviously
that's just the case i mean there are
people who come in and they already know
english
they're people who come in and they've
already had a history with western
democracy they're people who come in and
they've never seen a gay person before
and in their old country gay people were
caned and killed
so it's it's important to recognize that
cultures are not
the same thing as ethnicities and i
think it's a dangerous game to play
when we say that that ethnicity means
culture when they clearly do not mean
anything of the sort
hey ben how are you doing okay how are
you i'm good
um so unlike everyone else here i'm
actually a high schooler i represent i'm
the secretary of our young americans for
freedom charter
great and um we fought really hard to
try to get you to come to our school
too but um they shut us down every way
they could
um i know i got to keep this short but i
wanted to ask you
what's the best way as secretary i can
reach out to young
young people who may not know what
conservative is
and how can i inspire them to join the
movement that
pretty much you lead well that's very
kind of you um that's right i lead it
but uh that's nice of you
i think that uh as far as um how to get
people to join the movement
people join movements because they see
flashpoints in culture right the way
people most engage i can tell this from
the way that people
sort of find my content most of the
people who listen to my show for example
originally engaged because they saw a
short video of me
on youtube or facebook talking about
race or transgenderism or something
and then they they used that as sort of
a gateway drug to actually see the rest
of what i was talking about
and i think that the same holds true for
for politics in most situations
so the important thing if you're pushing
conservatism is to to find the flash
points this is true for everybody in
politics right left and center so it's
also true for conservatives
and that is you find a flash point that
inherently supports your position
and then you say this is why you need to
get politically engaged um
and you have to find out what the person
is really interested in not people not
everybody is interested in the same
issues there's some people who are very
interested
uh in the unborn there are some people
who are very interested in gun rights i
see the nra hat
are there a bunch of people who are who
are very interested in economic liberty
uh there are a bunch of people who are
libertarian and just don't want the
government involved in their business
and so you have to sort of identify what
is it what issue motivates somebody as a
general rule
and then determine how you make the
approach politically on a hot
button issue that's in the news because
that's first people have to be
interested and what makes people
interested
is those hot button flash points in
politics it's not
you telling somebody to go out and read
frederick hayek it's not going to happen
would it be all right if i got a picture
of uh i'd be happy to do that after i
think i think
we'll probably try and stick around a
little bit do that
uh hi so let's say hypothetically
there's a young man here who
is dating a young woman who tends to
lean very far left
so sorry before you go any further is
she is she present right now
no she is not okay good so i can be
honest all right
all right so how might uh like do you
have any advice for how this young man
might uh go about exposing her to some
new ideas without the relationship
crashing involved oh you're an optimist
okay
so you my friend are making a very large
mistake
i'm sure she's wonderful i'm sure she's
supremely attractive i'm sure all of
those things
it depends what the relationship is for
are you in it for marriage or like
you actually have to give me like what's
the end goal here uh yeah
marriage okay so if you're in it for
marriage then the number one thing you
must have in common with your spouse's
values
you don't have interests come after
values but most people are interested in
lots of things there are lots of
interesting things in the world
liking the same movies liking the same
art virtually worthless
what is important is that you have the
same value system so politics are a
reflection of values now there are a lot
of people
who never connect their politics with
their values so you have to determine
whether she's politically left because
this ref represents some core values or
just because she's been told a bunch of
slogans and now she repeats all these
slogans so when i first stated my wife
for example my wife thought of herself
as pro-choice and then the most the more
that we discussed the issue became very
clear to her that she was actually
pro-life and hadn't really considered
the issue in a serious way it was just
she was told on college campus that it
was a good thing to be pro-choice
and so she said she was pro-choice and
the same thing was true of
of gun rights for example uh she didn't
know anything about guns she'd been told
guns were bad
uh and then when i explained gun rights
to her and when it turned out that her
father was a member of the military
uh then uh then she then she shifted a
little bit politics is the tip of the
iceberg
the question is whether your your
girlfriend's politics
or this unnamed person's girlfriend's
politics uh are
are a floating bit of flotsam on the top
of the ocean or whether there's actually
a structural
underpinning for for what she's thinking
so you first have to determine that
if there is a structural underpinning
and if she really believes this stuff on
a strong level
you're really going to have to think
about whether this is something you want
to go through for the next 80 years
because it's because when it comes time
to raise your kids
forget about you okay in my view
marriage is marriage not relationships
marriage is about bearing and rearing
children
uh ideally right my wife and i have two
children uh that is the end goal of
marriage
uh that is the telos of marriage
marriage was created so that we could
bear and raise our children and that
means that we have to have
very similar perspectives on how we want
to raise our kids now if you want to
raise your kid with traditional ideas of
virtue and decency and she wants to
raise your kids with traditional ideas
of multiculturalism for example
then and all cultures and all opinions
being equal all behavior being equal
this is going to be a real conflict when
it comes time to parent your kids so
you so you have to ask yourself two
questions one is she movable
and two if she's not movable what is
your end goal here
because you know there's lots of fun to
be had in life but when it comes time
for marriage marriage is
as all the married people in the room
know marriage is not the time for fun
you know marriages when it comes when it
comes time for marriage
you know i've not totally tried i love
my wife and we have a great marriage but
see i know she's watching but it's it
but
but uh when it comes time for marriage
it is deeply important
that you put values before all of the
other ancillary things if you have
values in common your marriage can
outlast anything if you don't have
values in common then the first break
and the thing's over
[Applause]
hey ben i'm the founding chairman of the
young young americas
for freedom here on campus we're almost
an official group that you you just have
to
recognize us we have two people to go so
that's good news i'm also a convert from
milo yiannopoulos to you
which is pretty good but my question you
discovered virtue congratulations
yes thank you uh one issue here on
campus is renaming buildings
one of our buildings is named kaufman
union it's after one of our former
presidents
and he's been accused of racism and
anti-semitism
in your opinion should we apply today's
values to the past
in renaming monuments and buildings so
as a general rule i think not uh
this is i think that monuments the names
on buildings this is actually a good
educational opportunity i don't like the
phrase teachable moment but they usually
are
so this idea that we're going to chip
off all of the names from old buildings
i think that's foolish i think it's
actually very important as a as a
country
for us to face up to the problems that
we've had in the past
so over at princeton there's the woodrow
wilson college over princeton and they
were talking about whether they're going
to chip his name
off the building i think woodrow wilson
was one of the worst presidents we ever
had i think wardrobe wilson was a
terrible human being
but i think it would be important to
actually mention that right he was the
president of princeton and i think
it's important to say listen there was a
time in our history
that racism was not just a thing it was
a dominant thing
there was a time in our history where
the first amendment was not protected
the where the birth of a nation was
screened in the white house by this guy
right the movie about the the glories of
the kkk was screened in the white house
for woodrow wilson
um i think all of that is useful and i
think all of that is good because if we
don't know our history
number one we don't know how far we've
come and number two it's a reminder of
how things can go bad if we revert back
into our tribal nature
so if i don't know anything about the
person who you mentioned but
if it turns out that that person did a
lot of terrible things then i think it's
important to recognize that people are
people there's a mixed legacy usually
with a lot of these folks
thomas jefferson was one of the great
thinkers in in human history
and he held slaves and he had six
children by sally hemings you know this
is
that is a horrible evil thing to do but
that doesn't mean that everything that
he ever did was terrible
so i think that it's important that we
recognize what's what we've done right
in the past what we've done wrong in the
past
and it's a mistake to obliterate history
i just think it's i think it's
and that's not just my perspective
that's the perspective of condoleezza
rice you said the same thing
and i think she's absolutely correct
hey ben howdy uh so i've been following
you since
uh your peers morgan interview years
back that was awesome
uh question so i hear you put a lot of
emphasis on the free market
fixing uh for example like racism and
being self-regulatory
a pure example of this is if a business
refuses business to a minority
a competing business will pop up and
steal a business of folks who found the
former business immoral
and that will run the racist business
out of business if you're following me
here all right
all right so with the country so large
as the united states couldn't there
still be enough niche market to keep the
original business afloat
if there is enough of a niche market to
keep it afloat does the government have
the responsibility to make it illegal to
refuse
service based on the code of someone's
skin or do you see that as
government overreach setting bad
precedence so i think that there's
certainly
niche markets for racism i mean there's
still people who sell racist crap online
and and do just fine with it
but the question is are these people who
are going to thrive and also
are we willing to sacrifice your right
to freedom of association in order to
crack down
on a few bad actors and this is always
the question when it comes to rights
it's the same question with gun rights
are we willing to crack down on hundreds
of millions of
100 million gun owners in the united
states in order to get the few bad
actors
are willing to crack down on freedom of
association for hundreds of millions of
people
in order that we get a few bad actors
particularly when the market prevents
these people from becoming wildly
successful
they are punished by the market because
if you're a racist you can only cater to
that niche as opposed to
being able to cater to a broader
possible audience the best example
of of integration by the way through the
free market uh
is woolworth's the the woolworths
counter which was boycotted in 1960
before the civil rights act by a bunch
of black students who walked in and they
said that they wanted
to be served and the restaurant said
well by local law we cannot serve you
and they said well we're just going to
sit here until you do
and pretty soon the entire world will
change changed its segregation policy
and that's because they're a bunch of
people who said we're not going to shop
there anymore right the montgomery bus
boycott is another example of this sort
of stuff working
i think that that is is effective i
think it's actually more effective now
than it was then because then
you're at least bound by location right
what if there was no competing business
that could find a place to rent across
the street now everything's online
so you can get anything online now all
these people who are walking into
christian bakers and demanding that they
serve their same-sex wedding first of
all if you can't find a gay baker in the
united states i don't know where you
live
but second of all
but second of all there are lots of cake
making companies that you can go online
and just buy a cake from them
and if that christian is willing to lose
the business well then the christian's
willing to lose the business it seems to
me that's a much better cure
for the problem of supposed
discrimination than
saying that we are going as a government
to regulate who you can and cannot
serve as uh as a client uh as as i
pointed
i point this out to jimmy kimmel who was
doing this one of my favorite punching
bags
uh jimmy kimmel was was saying this
about exactly this case with the gay
bakers and i said well jimmy
i would like for you to write me a
comedy routine about the nastiness and
horrors of hillary clinton barack obama
and i demand you do so right now
right this is your skill set how dare
you deny me service just because i'm a
conservative you're going to deny me
service that's discrimination
how could you do such a thing the same
principle that allows jimmy kimmel to
refuse me service
allows the the christian couple to
refuse to serve the same-sex
wedding um and i'm i'm pretty extreme
when it comes to
you know the freedom of association i
think that you should be able to reject
anybody from your business you want to
even if you're a piece of crap and you
reject people you really shouldn't
are you still going to push for debate
oh i'm happy to debate jimmy kimmel
anytime anywhere
can you wake me up in the middle of the
night let's do it
hi how's it going so yeah i was a
socialist in eighth grade
actually until i got cognitive
dissonance watching your uh
pierce morgan interview but since then
i'm a senior now in high school and i
founded the yaf chapter
and for you that's great so yeah i mean
it would be great if we could get a
photo for publicity it'd be great for
the city
yeah like i said we'll try and get some
photos afterward but uh so yeah
when you're arguing with atheists in the
end of the argument of morality
there's almost always a concession that
there's no objective right or wrong
as a christian or a religious person how
can we prove that there's an objective
morality without explicitly citing
religion
so there's so there's two basic
approaches to
morality both of which rely on an
unmoved mover
one is the more secular greek approach
and one is the judeo-christian approach
the judeo-christian approach is
revelation
right either in the judaic version god
came down on a mountaintop and informed
people what was good and what was right
and what was wrong and what we should do
and what we should not
uh and in the and in the christian
version jesus came to earth
uh and gave a moral code um so there's
revelation
and then there's and then there's the
the greek teleology which essentially
suggests that there's an unmoved mover
that caused the universe to be the way
that it
that it is and in the very nature of the
universe itself
you can discover rules for living so
this is the difference between the
aristotelian good for example
and what you would consider just moral
good so you might say that something
happens and that's bad or that's good
what aristotle would say
is it's not that something happens and
it's bad or good it's fit or unfit
meaning that
certain things are created for certain
purposes so for example what makes a
what makes a a shovel good is its
capacity to dig
right so a good shovel the way he uses
good is this way a good shovel is a
shovel that you can dig with
a good man is a man who can reason right
because what man is uniquely created to
do is reason what human beings or his
people as
justin trudeau would say are capable of
doing is reasoning
and so the more you use your reason that
is what you were put on earth to do
and then you can derive a certain set of
rules people were meant to do justice
based on the nature of who people are
people were meant to get married and
have babies based on the nature of what
sex is
right these so you can derive some rules
from that
now that was basically i would say torn
apart by a lot of enlightenment thinkers
ranging from david hume to voltaire to
uh to spinoza
but i don't know that they sufficiently
reject that argument because then they
go
find a moral system on their own uh or
either they find an arbitrary moral
system or they try to reconstruct a
moral system based on premises that are
not available in nature
right they try to set up universal
principles like kant tries to do
but that's a universal principle khan
came up with so it's inherently
subjective
so you either if you want an object of
morality you either have to go to the
nature of things and try to derive from
the nature of things what you ought to
do you have to connect to isn't ought in
a way that david kim would not like
or you have to go to revelation and say
here is what god
actually said to human beings and
instructed them to do now the good news
is
that the vast majority of things that
the greeks thought were good
are also the same things that are
thought good in judeo-christian
systems of thought which is what aquinas
says what maimonides says it's what
augustine says even
even though he's attempting to draw some
distinctions uh christianity
historically speaking was maybe the
first attempt to actually meld to the
thought of judea
judaic thought with greek thought which
is why the new testament is written in
greek
uh as opposed to being written in
aramaic or a hebrew which was the
parliament of the time
so all of that is a very long way in a
historical way
to say that no one has yet come up with
a system of morality that is objectively
verifiable
and that actually gives us all the
things we want outside of the history
that i just gave to you so this is what
i said to sam here so sam harris comes
to a lot of the same
moral conclusions that i do right that
we have individual rights and that we as
individual human beings shouldn't hurt
each other and that we have the right to
free speech and that we have the right
to property and what i said to him is
there's an entire
two three thousand year history to get
us to those rights
right born out of judeo-christian and
greek thought and you're just taking the
cherry off the top and proclaiming that
this is obvious to everyone
and clearly that's not the case because
for the vast majority of people on earth
for all of human time
that is not true and this has been our
our main
disagreement uh and again i think that
it's very difficult for for sam or for
atheists generally
to get to a moral system that is not
arbitrary it may be a system that i
agree with they may have morality that i
agree with but it's hard for them to say
this is objectively true
on any level without some appeal to
either the nature of things
or some appeal to god himself
hey ben so i'm definitely a left-leaning
student um but i listen to your podcast
every day well thank you for coming and
thank you for listening i appreciate it
thank you thank you
uh so my question uh is about race and
culture
so while i agree with you that when you
look at white america it's silly to say
that the majority of white americans
are actively trying to prevent you from
getting to where you want to be
i'm east indian and i have definitely
experienced some racism but i never felt
as though it keeps indians from
succeeding
so i do think there's a cultural
component that supersedes the color of
your skin
but i also think that it's naive to say
that it just so happens that the same
minority groups that have been
historically oppressed
happen to have cultures that are less
conducive to success
i believe that environment can create
culture can you acknowledge the
historical reasonings that led
that these so-called unsuccessful
cultures and not put blame on these
minority groups
i know that in your heart i don't think
you're a racist person but in my
in my opinion to blame people for their
failure
for their cultural failures without
taking into consideration
the history in general conceals a lack
of empathy and sort of pins at racism
okay so i'll fight back on the last
point that that
you know there's anything to do with
empathy or racism here um but
i fully agree with you like 100 not like
90 like 100
i think the bad cultures are generally
the result of bad things that have
happened
in the past or bad modes of thought that
have prevailed over time
so for example uh there's a great book
by thomas soule uh
called uh black rednecks and white
liberals uh and that book essentially
suggests that a lot of the
pa the pathologies that exist about
single motherhood for example in the
black community or high rates of
violence
are actually outgrowths of a slave and
post-slave culture that was imposed
by a white society that didn't bother
with policing that didn't in
that didn't care about inculcating
morals or virtues in
in slaves obviously they actually
actively fought against it because they
didn't want that to happen
um and so there was an active fight from
a symbol against assimilation
by white people and that created an
underground culture that's really bad
and that existed in parts of white
america too it exists in appalachia so
yes i think bad cultures have nothing to
do with race uh i don't think that just
because
this is why i'm saying i don't know why
borders on racism to say the cultures
are bad like some cultures are bad some
cultures are good and that has nothing
to do with race
charles murray wrote an entire book
called coming apart about pathologies in
white communities
uh that that are really destructive so
bad cultures do arise
very often from historical circumstances
including historical discrimination
what i say is that today there's nothing
preventing an individual
from superseding the culture in which
you grew up and making good decisions
in the free country somebody's going to
have to break this chain somebody's
going to have to break this cycle
and so am i going to bl i don't care if
you want to if you want to
say that that the pathologies that exist
in the black community uh black inner
city community of
high rates of single motherhood and
violence for example um or
lack of institutional wealth uh that
that is a result of historic racism i'm
fine with you saying that i don't have
any problem with that i'm not talking
about historical racism when i talk
about white privilege
i'm talking about right now the idea
that there's a superstructure of rules
and laws
that are preventing you from succeeding
or a culture that is trying to keep you
down i don't think that's the case so
the question becomes
if you are here let's say let's say that
on average the culture
in white america uh or with regard to
single motherhood to take an example
uh is is here right because there's less
single motherhood in the white community
than the black community
and in the black community it's it's
here because it's 70 single motherhood
rate and the white
community is 40 okay so the question is
before thanks to racism and thanks to
discrimination there was a cap on the
black community that was here
and they couldn't get past it okay now
the ceiling's been removed so what do
you as an individual black person do
to change your life and i don't think
it's helpful and
in fact i think it's actually quite
hurtful to spend an enormous amount of
time
talking about the legacy of
discrimination and racism instead of
talking about what can you do right now
to fix your problem now this is a
general
issue that i have in all of my
relationships when my wife comes to me
and she says there's a problem in my
life before we even have the
conversation i say to her is this a
listening
conversation or is this that you want me
to fix that conversation
and i think that when it comes to
politics there should be far fewer
listening conversations like i want you
to tell me about all the crap that's
happening because i don't care
i mean i care but it doesn't but now the
question is what you're gonna do
right that's a much more important
conversation because we only have five
minutes together
is that five minutes gonna be spent on
all the terrible things that happened
which i fully agree with
that i would have fought if i were there
but i wasn't right are we gonna spend
five minutes talking about all the
terrible things that happened to blacks
and jews and gays and women and and
hispanics in the united states are we
gonna talk about right now what you can
do to succeed because i don't think that
the rules are holding you back
so i've never ever at any point
suggested that there's not been historic
discrimination against black people
or even that current day poverty is at
least in part in outgrowth
of that historic discrimination what i
have suggested is that if you're using
that historic discrimination as a reason
why you are not
as an individual human being becoming
more income mobile
and not making good decisions no one is
making the call for you right now as an
individual to get that girl pregnant
and that's that's the argument that i'm
making
sure yeah um so i guess
like would you like so don't you you
have to admit though that
between different races and different
cultures there are there are different
levels of success and
there's definitely you would expect that
somebody who grows up with
with uh with less with being able less
to succeed you you would
you would expect that that would happen
in certain in certain communities and
certainly right that's why they're
called pathologies of culture yeah for
sure i mean if you grew up in a worse
situation than somebody else grew up in
a better situation of course you're
going to grow up
having obstacles that that other person
has to overcome but that doesn't mean
that that other person number one
victimized you
right there's no one in america today
for example who's enslaved a black
person
that i know of or if they have to be in
jail um i'm sure that nobody in this
room right none of the young white
people in this room
were alive during the times of jim crow
so the question is
do we take away from the white people in
this room to rectify historic injustices
or do we recognize that history is
filled with historic injustices
and now we're going to have to find a
way to overcome those obstacles together
without redistributing income for
example
now i have called for movements for
example for uh
for companies to go into inner cities
and make a deal with
students in inner cities and say to them
listen you get good grades and we'll pay
for your college and then you come
afterward and you work for us for three
years to pay off that debt
i think there are things that we can do
in the private sector this is why i
think religious communities are so
important
i'm not against charity i'm not against
us as individuals going out and helping
people
what i am against is the idea that the
government can fix this problem because
the government cannot fix historic
inequity
all the government can do is set the
rules at an equal level equal law
equal you know equal judgment under law
equal justice under law
is the only way that we're ever going to
approach anything that looks like a fair
society there's no such thing as a fair
society where the government plays god
and gives them to others and takes from
others so
would you would you say that you
basically we should
like other people who are not you know
in an oppressed state they should
they should wait and wait for other
people to pull themselves up uh
do you think that's how we should solve
or do you think there is i think every
culture in american history every
individual in american history who has
succeeded
has had a combination of people who help
them out not in the government people
who help them out
and their own capacity to bootstrap it
and when my
great grandparents got here they were
dirt poor and didn't speak english uh
great great grandparents got here
they're dirt poor and didn't speak
english
this is true for virtually everybody in
the room right at some point somebody
came over here and they were dirt poor
and didn't speak english
uh and that doesn't mean that on a
generational level people are gonna go
from
from zero to a hundred um but it does
mean that we're gonna need to move in
the right direction as opposed to
sitting around and talking about
historic injustice all day
because that doesn't get anything done
thanks so much
ben so uh i've listened to a lot of your
content over the years
um so i think i know most of your
viewpoints on things but one thing that
i've never heard you
uh explicitly bring up and that in my
opinion
is be is going to becoming much more of
an issue
um is the legislation or lack thereof of
artificial intelligence
um could you expand on like your
thoughts on that because there have been
um certain people who are calling for uh
significant legislative legislation on
that
and others that are vehemently opposing
it so as a as a libertarian i'm
pretty opposed to the idea of limiting
the expansion into artificial
intelligence i think that
uh there may be some moral issues
involved you know
once you get to black mirror level where
you're quote unquote you know creating
individual human beings with the
capacity to make decisions for example
and do these things have some form of
human rights but i'm not sure that
that's
anywhere around the corner right now
these artificial intelligence
systems uh are you know they're great at
certain things and really bad at others
so uh i'm i think that's a bridge that
we'll have to cross when we come to it
you don't
like i don't think you have to foresee
the moral problems coming i think they
will just show up
so i don't think we had to first see the
stem cell moral issue coming up until it
came up and then we had to deal with it
so preemptively guarding against
technology that we haven't discovered
yet is sort of self-defeating
because we can't predict every piece of
technology that's going to come down the
pipe plus there's going to be a bunch of
people who go around the law anyway to
develop such technology
particularly when you're talking about
computer technology and not just
like it takes a fair amount of resources
to to do this in bio in biology
i'm not sure that quite the same thing
holds true when you have the capacity
for the internet
um you know i'm i'm less worried about
technology than a lot of other folks
i know there are a lot of people who are
worried that it's going to kill every
job and that it's going to destroy
human beings as we know it and that
skynet's going to kill us all and all
this
um yeah maybe maybe but so far that's
been said about every technological
development in the history of mankind
and then we've created
new types of jobs now maybe i'm wrong
maybe this is a difference in kind maybe
it turns out the machines can think
better than we do and we can just turn
everything over to them well if that's
the case then we're gonna have a lot of
leisure time won't we
because these machines presumably making
good at things we'll be good at making
things that we like
we'll have basically the star trek
replicator and at that point when all
resources are no longer scarce but
plentiful then we can sit around and
watch vikings games
[Applause]
mr shapiro thank you for coming out here
it's it's time to listen to you
uh i'm bennett and i am a junior in high
school part of the
uh yaf chapter that we have and just a
question for you uh
kind of about you know it's been two
months since the tax bill has passed
and just uh asking your perspective on
you know only about
forty five fifty percent of uh american
households pay taxes
and what is your perspective on that
when also not everyone has an opinion on
uh where taxes should be allocated when
only about fifty percent of
households actually pay taxes and just
kind of your perspective on that
so just quick correction you mean income
taxes yeah federal income tax only about
50 percent of american households pay
federal income tax
uh virtually all households pay some
form of tax rate pay sales tax or they
pay state tax or property tax or that
kind of stuff
so the answer is that it is bizarre to
me that
you know we should give a lot of
credibility to the opinion of people who
are not affected by
a given policy except that they get tax
refunds
from the government for taxes that they
are not paying for example
i always thought that the argument that
was being made by republicans on this
that all people
are in the country are going to get tax
cuts i thought the individual tax cut
side was actually kind of dumb because
the people who are paying the tax in the
country
as i mentioned in the speech are largely
at the upper end of the income bracket
they're not people who are at the lower
end of the income bracket so
it's a problem i mean i do think that as
we shift that burden more and more
toward the upper end of the income
spectrum it's going to be very easy for
the 70 of the public that's paying not
very much tax to
uh to put all the tax burden on the
other 30 to the public
and there's gonna come a point where
people at the upper end of the tax
spectrum are sick of that and they just
start doing all their business offshore
uh which is one of the reasons why i was
in favor of the tax cut not
not even because it would help me
because it wouldn't i live in california
i actually pay more taxes under this tax
bill
um but because i think that it's
important that we bring business back
from overseas and the only way to do
that is to make the tax rates
uh fiscally fiscally friendly to to
people who actually want to create jobs
in the country
hi mr sparrow thank you for coming
tonight um just want to start by saying
i was the chair of the college
republicans here from 99 to 2000
former gop staffer and just want you to
know i'm on the team
um but now that said yeah that said i
work for the university now mm-hmm
um and you've always been a champion for
honest debate um
i'm aware of both sides of the argument
around you being in saint paul tonight
um with only one date to work with that
you were available to be here
you were given the largest available
room on campus
and i'm just wondering um your
organizers of this event helped select
the room
i have the emails to back then um so
isn't
yaf threatening a first amendment
lawsuit about your location
falling into the victim mentality that
identity politics is based on
so i will be honest with you i've been
taking the in
the information i'm getting i'm getting
from yf and from the students so i
assume they would tell a different story
than the one that you're telling because
that's the story they've been telling me
if i look at both sides of the issue and
it turns out that
that's the case that you guys basically
just came to an agreement this is the
best available place that
uh that you couldn't find a bigger hall
that we actually needed a hundred cops
you know that that all that is the case
uh then i'm more than happy to say that
i think that
that would be victim mentality and we
shouldn't do that uh what i am seeing is
a pattern across the country
of this sort of stuff happening on a
routine basis specifically
citing security needs and i think that
that's something we have to take into
account and that's something that's
dangerous like this is this is not the
first university
where members of the general public uh
have been
you know there are a lot of universities
where members of the general public have
been barred
there are a lot of universities where
they've shifted me to other smaller
sites
there are lots of universities where
they canceled me outright because of
this
and so if in this situation that's not
what's happening i'm perfectly happy to
attract
my critique of the university if the
university legitimately did the best
that it could
and you have the emails to back that up
and all of that
more than happy to say that it's
inappropriate for anyone to go after you
more than happy to do that um but there
is a heckler's video to say and it's
also possible that you guys didn't do
anything wrong but what's happening is
that security situations are becoming so
complex because of
the left and because of what they're
doing that it's a bad situation for
everybody
all around my suggestion is you know
again i'm from the outside
all i can see is that i walk through a
room downstairs with literally a hundred
police officers in it i don't know if
there are any protesters outside my
guess is probably not if there are there
are very few
um it's cold uh by my standards uh and
so the
and so if you're going to staff a
hundred police officers it seems weird
to me that we can't do it at all that
that holds 200 to 200 people as opposed
to 500 but again
as i say if you show me the evidence i'm
more than happy to change my opinion on
it
all right this will be the last question
hey ben
uh with the current republican congress
unable to pass much of the conservative
agenda such as repealing obamacare
repealing daca and lowering the budget
do you think that there will be a
conservative movement in the future that
reduces the scope of government
dramatically or will conservatives have
to continue to sacrifice their larger
wants in order to get smaller victories
like the end of chain migration and if
you love the individual mandate i mean i
think that for the moment smaller
victories are basically what's in the
offing i think that in the future
circumstances change and we're in for
some pretty hard times
and i'm i'm talking about particularly
the deficit right now
people are just ignoring the fact that
the national debt is up to 21 trillion
dollars when bill clinton left office it
was 5.2 trillion dollars
that is a shocking multiplication and
every
nation that has ever had this kind of
debt in in proportion to its gdp
ends up having to take some sort of
austerity measures so those austerity
measures are coming
the only question is when they're going
to happen uh and democrats aren't going
to put those in place
so that means that as circumstances
change it's up to us to stand out there
with the sign saying the end is near
even when people are saying that things
are booming and and
growing all over the place it's one of
my chief critiques of of
the policy of the trump administration
is that they've been utterly
uninterested in entitlement reform which
is i think
the single most important thing that the
government could actually do at this
point and republicans are running away
from it headlong because they're afraid
of losing elections
at a certain point you're going to have
to you know you're going to have to sack
up guys and actually do something
important
as opposed to passing tiny bits of
legislation that are supposed to please
us
well thanks so much thank you for having
me i really appreciate it